[Music]
it's a question which has been dividing
allies for weeks will Germany release
the leopard tube battle tanks to fight
in Ukraine now finally an answer seems
imminent a diplomatic source told me
German approval for Poland to send its
leopard two tanks as expected this week
with German media reporting the
chancellor is also likely to send some
of their own stock nothing is official
until Olaf Schultz makes an announcement
and one of the questions which has been
delaying this decision is whether by
sending battle tanks they could escalate
the war in Ukraine by acting alone
biling could be a Target so I'm told
that Germany has been looking for a
similar commitment from allies
particularly the U.S
this is what America has on the table
it's much prized Abrams a speculation
swirled it was poised to send them as
part of a joint package of heavy weapons
the Pentagon refused to be drawn I have
no announcements to make at this time
and when and if we do we'll be sure to
let you know Britain has already
confirmed it's sending 14 Challenger
twos
vital weapons in a conflict President
Putin is showing no desire to end soon
the only way to last in peace is to make
it clear to Putin that he will not win
on the battlefield
therefore we must provide heavier and
more advanced systems on the
battlefields of Ukraine troops in Soviet
era equipment are desperate for modern
machines experts say a delivery of
Battle Tanks could be crucial it does
give them a punch it certainly evens out
the odds on the battlefield and it gives
Ukraine the option of an attack that at
the moment is a little bit less likely
for them to be able to do and succeed
the German government says a decision
will come soon but refuse to comment
further
while the weight continues in Ukraine
there are fresh hopes that the tanks
they've been pleading for could soon be
on their way Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Berlin